[Music]
speaking of funerals what a transition
huh I like the fans are not privy to I
don't get I I get invited to more
weddings than funerals that's you bummed
out about that there will there will be
a time in our lives where we're going to
be going to more funeral because of all
the weddings later you'll have more
funerals uh so like you know being grown
up in a church I feel like when what I
miss about that Community is there's
always something from birthdays to
weddings to funerals and [__] right and
I feel like that's missing in my life
don't you worry once you have kids yeah
lot of funeral our neighbor okay uh she
told me she was like last year because
her kid just went into kindergarten they
went to 40 birthdays that's so he's like
don't you worry about that I cannot wait
but you have a kid y birthday parties
every [__] weekend some days you got
two three birthdays go to all right so
instead of birthdays let's bring it back
to death
all right funerals are pretty heavy huh
birthday birthday birthday so uh there
was apparently this uh stench that led
officials to 189 rotting corpses at a
taxidermist funeral home that's TI was
going to be smelly huh that's hor did
they not have
refrigeration someone unplugged it
that's yeah that's what it is somebody
unplugged their Refrigeration yeah oh
that's to the end of this article cuz
189 that's normal they're supposed to
have dead bodies at a taxidermist place
right that's the normal part but the
stinky is the not normal part uh it's
not supposed to be a taxid dermis place
it's supposed to be
uhum yep what is it called what you say
a m culen a
micum a
cryptography
yep
chorum well this home The Return To
Nature Funeral Home in Penrose Colorado
claimed to conduct environment mentally
friendly Green burials yeah right dude
what's that mean yeah right like you
just dig a hole and throw your grandpa
in there you let it decompose naturally
they don't do the faldy that's going to
smell like [__] don't they put faldy is
that what they do what formaly to like
preserve the body yeah yeah yeah when
you're in bombing that smells funny that
smells crazy I like that when it's a
like at Afters they have that flavor
it's actually pretty good no dude it's
imagine [__] sick so it first came to
the attention of local
authorities after reports of a Puget
smell pouring from the company neglected
building local Federal authorities
executed a search warrant and initially
found 115 improperly stored bodies at
the facility which is about 100 miles
south of Denver that same day a Colorado
state official the program director of
The Office funeral home and creatory
registration spoke directly with the
owner and operator of Return To Nature
and in the conversation acknowledged
that he had a problem at the facility
and claimed he practiced Taxidermy there
in so he made Taxidermy humans or you
mean like animals he just wasn't good at
it he was playing around maybe he was
playing around doesn't specifically say
he was doing humans and or animals
working out the Kinks he was practicing
Taxidermy there but uh in an order of
summary there they noted that the
facility had operated without a license
since the the last November so he also
reported that this dude attempted to
conceal the improper storage of human
remains at the facility so basically he
was just doing some really weird [__]
when you say practice Taxidermy it makes
me worried a little bit it just sounds
bad you know like sounds like this guy
yeah it's like this is Jeffrey dmer
adjacent you think anybody who goes into
taxidermia is like right on the edge
Hannah's cousin's a professional
taxidermist not necessarily her [__] got
viral it's the it's the creepy Fox oh
really that's Hannah [__] the fox
that's sitting like this [__] with the
funky eyes the funk so her specialty is
doing weird and like like you know not
like all perfect as [__] but like just
in funny POS like yeah I don't know
Hip-Hop Hip-Hop squirrel hip hop
squirrel is that disrespectful you think
like foxes would be like yo this is
tight they're hyped about it would their
like families come back and be like yo
that's my
cousin avenge their
cousin or like is that disrespectful cuz
it' probably be disrespectful if you
like put Nana in a like a b boy St
upright like this with leg with their
legs
upe that be [__] fresh yeah I just
made up the hip-hop part of it but he's
just being a cute little fox just
sitting that's a really famous [__]
tax is that's that's Hannah's cousin
can't believe that's Hannah's cousin
that's czy that's Hannah's cousin and
wait Hannah's cousin's I'm just my my my
wife's cousin his wife's cousin's a fox
it means that it's my relative
too that's your cousin your cousin your
cousin [__] with dead animals well I
never met this lady but the um the funny
thing is so she's such an artist the
thing is she wasn't making any royalties
or anything from that thing until a fan
that's a lawyer helped her go get um
everything copywritten and [__] cuz I
think that's in uh what the meme even
yeah yeah yeah yeah so like you you're
saying like from stuff like that she
wasn't making royalties but somebody
like took that as and help and helped
that well yeah it was going all over the
place but you know how artists are they
just like they're grateful that their
art actually made it into something they
don't know about like they don't think
artists don't know anything about money
talk about how dumb they are you know
what one of my lowkey dreams are to have
like uh you know when you go to like a
KTV and they're always playing random
ass clips of [__] uh I hope that just
kenja videos are just randomly a shitty
ass karaoke spots TI it's better than a
[__] girl riding a bike at next to a
pond for no reason that's what I'm
saying they're just random [__] anyway
just Eastern European b-roll in um in
the music videos that you're actually in
for artists those are probably at some
ktvs yeah but like KTV I like at shitty
b-roll type stuff you know what are you
talking about cuz sometimes you'll just
see a song that you obviously it might
be like Snoop Dogg or some [__] like
that anytv and then they're just playing
random ass dance video it's the
[__] the E and it's just a girl
riding a bike next to the [__] pond
it's like a Russian Park [__]
and a [__] Dove is flying leaves are
just going likey field to do with this
thing Filipino magic mic back were the
funniest you remember those cuz it was
always like like 8 bit pixelated cows on
a farm like and it would pan so [__]
slow pasture somewhere pure hey how sick
is that magic mic setup though I was
about to buy one it's amazing I mean but
I'm only thinking of like the late '90s
well the problem is even the newest
magic yeah but they don't have like the
newest songs I there's one somewhere cuz
I've been on no magic mic where they're
like here this is the new cartridge it's
like all the later songs like they
update them there has to be way to like
there has to be a way to find like get a
C I'm sure it's just like a
USB and load I'm trying to have cuz now
I have you know now I got Filipino
parties at you trying to get one trying
to get the best of the best I'm trying
to get a magic mic where like we
actually know the [__] songs and
stuff do you sing a lot now I suck but
Nina's
good I feel like all Filipinos know how
to sing I don't think I ever broke like
a 87 on my
score 87's hard to break though i' be
happy to break like a 65 well my get
that low on that 93 95 really that's
pretty tight Filipinos be getting 99s on
the randomst like chy Deton [__] like on
the randomst
song hey but according to Donan dude got
style I got style so much style but for
in terms of that I feel like anytime
someone's like trying to pitch a green
alternative you got to you got a better
you got extra check yeah yeah yeah cuz
if it's just natural then it's going to
stink cuz they'll just put it on their
title and not really do anything about
it it might be the same protocol they
don't [__] know that's true cuz if
I'm like hey I I live naturally what
does that really mean no
shower you know that means you don't
wipe my butt no toothpaste none of that
the toilet don't flush you just [__] in
it that's natural like that's messed up
to be like oh I want my grandma to have
a green burial so you like pay extra to
do this method and they just like
stuffed her in a closet at a taxidermist
like [__]
up well I mean she's decaying naturally
yeah but it was supposed to be beautiful
and like nicer than can you imagine the
dudes like they just grab her and then
they [__] go they just fold like
Jazzy Jeff out of a [__] like Jazzy
Jeff did you guys see that uh there's
like a company who like plant you as a
tree
yeah that's cool that's pretty but like
composting you into like soil yeah
basically oh it's like
that yeah they just plant a tree I
thought they stick you in the stump and
like you're just like in the wood would
you guys get taxid dermid no probably
not aider I'd rather be Char do you want
like a basic B burial cuz I feel like
all you guys are not basic people you
don't deserve a basic even legally get
text dery right isn't that like against
the law I'm trying to get cremated but
I'm down for a
maum what's a what's a be a that's
expensive it's like you know when you go
to the [__] and then you see a bunch
of here's a cross here's a tombstone and
then you see a giant [__] build out
that you can like walk inside like the
back rows of Rose Hills oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they're like
half a million dollars wait so the the
one that you go in though it's like it's
like an apartment for the dead though
they got all the plaques and [__] inside
right it's like a tough shed so those
are the Ballers you could build like a
big meline and have like your whole
family in there just for you they could
set it up too where they're glass and
then you get the taxidermist to put you
like in a superhero
so it's like when you're in Batman's you
know thing where he's got all the
different super suits but it's just you
and your family hella
dead dead and then you make sure the
refrigerator's turned
[Laughter]
on that's the biggest problem nowadays
with be sick though if you got all your
relatives and you recorded their like
last or most famous quotes like when you
go to like those Marvel exhibits you
could press the button say something
that be TI out was your mine I have no
idea yeah that' be that's a tough that's
tough to distill out right if you could
do that if you could have a mausoleum
that you can view your tax dery body
like how would you guys do it like I
would have them pose me and my family as
the family from us with like the
red my wife would have the scissors
right that's tight that's [__] scary
as [__] that's scary my family would
probably be like
this His Hands On The Wall will just be
him falling into guard choked out by
somebody falling into car falling like
just slipping it would just be like this
but then the arm is on a motor so it's
tapping
out push the button yeah push the button
you like pull a lever like this yeah tap
out but will be Bart will be behind Nick
his arms will be like this and it's like
an ex choke
like they're buried together not even
with family just for the bit that's your
dying wish
[Music]